je m'en excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur no time to explain un jeu
complètement keller bien what the fuck
you
j'arrive ces bons calmez-vous main sur
le capitaine donc voilà ça joue un peu
au fait qu'un homme vient nous chercher
il dit qu'il est le nom du futur
on se retrouve avec un chapeau de pirate
et un canon bizarre et on traverse un
portail bleu voilà l'histoire la plus
grave du monde
ok donc il ya des pics maintenant c'est
ça sa part en une fermez rios carrément
c'est ok j'ai pris une vie mais je ne
suis pas mort hier second niveau pas
c'est qu'en fait tu poses combat à
chaque fois refaire le truc qui
difficultés au nom a maudit pic bon
juhasz à la fraîcheur de la villa attend
mais ces destins lactique de picot les
[ __ ] chat on est bon un crabe attiré
dans un vaisseau un vaisseau avec une
carapace de tortue
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on doit yahya
yahya yahya je n'aime pas trop les
missiles mais qu'est ce que je suis dans
cette sphère et le vaisseau crabe tortue
tu te calmes et en fait dans ce jeu tu
ne meurent jamais c'est l'histoire ville
un vaisseau non apportés ville un
missile 1 le niçois a l'air d'être
emballant points c'est pas possible ça
va durer longtemps
oui on a sauvé monsieur crabes oh non
mais c'est un ennemi à en poster je
savais que ce n'est pas vrai crâne j'en
étais sûr aller la fais pas ta pince tu
vas mourir
[ __ ] l'espagne crabe 108 ans oui on
est sorti d'une pokéball blanche
incroyable à l'aube on y va à bon temps
qu'un faire autant continuer le jour où
cette histoire m'arrive
what the fuck merde c'est pas en classe
et monsieur crabe ici à quoi on va aller
dans celui-là oh merde allez [ __ ]
maniabilité de pages web
après le crash c'est leur cake poker la
villa requins tu auras du steak bien
j'ai un steak bien
bon bah c'est le moment où tu perds
parce que tu es du lot jamais allée
[ __ ] elle est là au [ __ ] ça me rend
dingue dingue dingue dingue dingue quand
ces lasers de la danse merde nos j'étais
dessus ça allait mais ça va bien entre
un moment non
allez m et ses bas mais allez on va leur
entrée pas la fin là ce hoquet iv mario
wii est c'est ça ça m'énerve un peu
regardé le requin là il est content de
lui là tu passeras jamais savoir
carrément cuiabá non mais quand mes
coups mais [ __ ] mais regarder mais
comme on est sur ces faits là des piques
vaart ou à mes [ __ ] tant attendu là
là je me fais pas avoir deux fois à
allah
non non non ah non non non et le mec qui
crient donc désactiver j'espère voilà un
qui commence à m'énerver alors aller là
où on affronte monsieur requins wata
phoque
c'est moi ou un mec vient d'arriver en
dix ans ferme ta gueule et ma mère
high-kick je crois que c'est bien ce qui
va se passer je n'étais pas sûr c'est
pour ça oui
vient un petit portail bleu à amay au
may hamm et oui non oui les spas avait
arrêté si vous jette mais ouais ça me
rend dingue la halle et oui on est allé
dans le trou ouais on a réussi non mais
pas que
oh [ __ ] ces trucs que je viens de
faire menu menu menu c'est au menu menu
back to the level s'élève à à agen le
mec qui a fait ça oui c'est l'heure
d'affronter le requin taupe les
messieurs requins qui se doit faire là
on doit foncer ou un [ __ ] de jet ski
au parfait aller où l'on retient juste
un gars de lola on s'approcherait plus
en plus souvent
hop salue au nom au [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh la vache j'ai eu peur oh oh
oh il rigole rigole parce que tu as fait
c'est comme au port on la fosse fight la
tiède pour moi their way j'espère qu'il
va juste pas manger une barre qu'au
passage parce que je le sens bien tiens
à vous visez la que tient la même table
que par la ville entend sa voix comme un
lézard il rapide que hélas tout mais
c'est quoi ce requin [ __ ] ils sont 120
toiles des toiles d'araignées arrête
arrête
non non je veux pas tomber à l'eau
j'étais très bien dans ma barque mais
alors la fin est-ce que faut aller en
fait peut-être sur sa tête comme ça et
bientôt
at c'est tout il est mort eh ben c'est
parfait ça et là mon père soit en a
marre alors on va arrêter de jouer à ce
jeu complètement waldhof en tout cas
merci beaucoup de regagner cette vidéo
est d'être nombreux tubes ça fait
vraiment plaisir c'est vraiment méga top
je vous dis à bientôt
à